you have a new hallmark Valentine's Day
movie coming out what a turd a night
it's called love romance and chocolate
we filmed it in Belgium and Bruges and
Brussels and it was such an amazing
experience and I can't wait for people
to see it I highly recommend you have
chocolates ready and with you while
you're watching it because they will
make you crave chocolate for sure ask
you party of five which just picked up
as a reboot it's gonna be on free bird
yes what do you make of that oh I think
it's awesome I mean hearty if I was such
a huge part of my life and I can't ever
say how thankful I am for these six
years of experience of getting to learn
so much about what it means to go into a
show and I'm so thankful people still
appreciate it and I can't wait to see
the new ones if they ask you to do a
cameo on it what is your response
oh of course I would I loved playing
Claudia she was a really fun character
and you know and very close with a lot
of the cast still and it's been nice
that we've been able to keep in touch so
absolutely how do you hope that they pay
respect to the original I haven't
thought about that I don't know I think
it's quite alluring to see how they
bring the you know the idea and
hopefully honor the original in some
sort of way but I think a fresh new
innovative take on it will be really
enjoyable to watch also big milestone
for Mean Girls 15 years in April 15
years how is that possible like
yesterday
I am actually going to New York soon and
I'm finally gonna get to see the musical
and I can't wait I've been wanting to
see it and it's just hard to get there
with being busy and having a toddler but
I can't wait to see it and that was such
a fun experience I will never forget
making that movie and I am I'm so
flattered people love it as much as they
do and still talk about it and I'm
honored to be part of it any chance that
you'll hop up on stage when you go no no
they haven't asked me to do that it's
probably best I just watch but I'm so
excited for them and I can't wait to see
it yeah what do you think of Lindsay
Lohan's new reality show have you got a
Channing it okay I haven't seen
but Lindsay's great I wish her the best
yes she was very excited about possibly
rebooting Mean Girls she's on board for
it any conversations in the past couple
of months about that has she reached out
at all no I haven't heard anything about
it officially but like I said it was
such a fun character that I think it
would be so much fun to revisit these
women and see where they are now but who
knows your daughter Judy asking for a
sibling oh no no she is the queen and
she would like it to remain that way but
yeah I mean it's it's definitely
something that I would I you know would
love to possibly have another one I'm in
no rush so we'll see what happens but
yeah she is the light of my life and she
keeps me on my toes she's she's the
princess for sure will you let her watch
Mean Girls well she's already seen the
scene where we're doing Jingle Bell Rock
and dancing yeah I was on TV and we were
flipping channels because that's mama
recognized yeah and she recognizes me
alive from the hallmark movies it she
goes mama dear you are there you are and
it's it's really sweet but obviously I
haven't let her watch much of what I've
been in but eventually all let her see
it and that is one of the things I love
about doing the hallmark movies I know
there are things that I can let her
watch and enjoy and family I'm very very
very proud to be a part of it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]